the only reason why i truly couldn't go
into space is because if you don't give
me an option to call my mother and ask
her what to do i can't do anything yeah
so i would have to answer
you call your mom and you ask her what
to do and then she tells you
and you do the complete opposite yeah
it's just what it is it's just what
happened yeah you just say ma you're
making really good sense
but i live life in what's known as the
fast lane so give me a black and white
fully charge me and get me out there to
somebody's [ __ ] yeah cause
if your life was a highway it would be
the german autobahn i'd be the autobahn
there is no speed limit you can only go
too slow
fast you can't go too slow cause you
sold your apartment you lived there for
13 minutes i sold my apartment to a
chinese national it's what it is they
offered straight cash
because the government is subsidizing uh
citizens of china
to buy real estate in new york and not
occupy it and i was against it but then
when they came in with 10 g's over the
asking price in full cash money
i said i'm going to take it absolutely
[Laughter]
wei jong-jan there you go it's what it
is i mean i mean binky mike
the poor kid i mean we just got the
mixer and he figured he'd be able to
have this episode ready
right after we're finished but to no
avail
chrissy came out firing it firing cuz
and mike instead
i was never stuck i've never done a
podcast 13 seconds after i watched it
from a nap
mikey instead of instead of putting the
chinese flag over the rant i just did
just
put all you know make sure you block out
my mouth so they can't read my lips but
just put an egg
do that yeah and then just you gotta do
it that's all you gotta do
and then that's the same thing
that one you got a [ __ ]
that one you have to just [ __ ] you
might have to fade to black on that one
or fade to white whatever it is i don't
want to be negative full edit on that as
well
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about
this is just a stock thing that we're
taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild